hey tanisha we are good when you are
good
all right we'll start off with my trail
hey anthony after you hit the shot it
looked like on the video that you moused
kobe
uh not sure if that was actually the
case but i wanted to ask you your
your feeling and and just to take us
through that moment
um i did you know i mean obviously
wearing the jerseys
um he's
countless uh shots like that you know to
win games
um regular season playoffs finals um
but i mean it's a special one for me
especially for my teammates
uh you know i told brian
that uh in in l.a you know right before
the hiatus
against brooklyn against the brooklyn
nets and you know same spot
um slightly different play and i missed
the shot
um and i i was upset at myself he said
man we're going to live without you
shooting that shot
um and i got the same opportunity
tonight we're able to make it
but i mean it's a special moment for me
especially for the team
um especially in a situation like this
trying to go up too well against a
special team who's
you know who great competitors and you
know going to
go on a fight for the entire 48 minutes
so
to do something like that you know and
in the jersey reward tonight
it just makes it even more special game
two of the western conference finals
three-pointer to win the game how close
to that is uh was it a dream of uh
anthony davis growing up in chicago how
how much of that kind of moment comes up
um it's a huge dream uh to make it
you know even better you kind of wish he
was a staples tonight
um with the fans that support us
all year but you know still to be in
that moment and hit a shot like that
is still a dream um
i've never hit a game winner like that
before
so it's a hit like that and to be a
three
uh special moment for me um
something i'll let's soak in for next
couple hours and then
uh tomorrow try to get you know get
ready and prefer for game three but
um you know being around you know braun
and you know dust and all the other guys
they
they for sure gonna let me you know make
sure i hear about it at least for the
rest of the night so
um so uh
um when you got teammates like this and
the coaching staff who
support you and want you to be great and
want the best for you
you know moments like this are even
better
hey it's dave um great shot man uh
frank was miked up and during the
broadcast we could hear him say
something to you guys during a time out
saying hey look at the jersey
you guys are wearing on your chest um
you hit the shot you guys are
undefeated in the jersey if you miss it
you're not um
is there any extra mojo going on with
with the jerseys that you guys been
wearing these playoffs those black mama
ones
we just feel like we play a little
different um our swag is a little
different
um you know every time we put on those
jerseys
obviously you know we're representing
him um
but you know especially in those jerseys
you know it says jersey the ones he
created so
anytime we put it on we feel like we
want to we want to win and
uh you know coach made sure that you
know we knew that
you know in that huddle i said i mean
look at the journeys you have on
um you know he would make big time play
so it's time for us to make big time
plays i think it's like six minutes left
in the game
uh you know guys were able to do that so
just looking down at the jersey and
coach telling us just a constant
reminder that
you know kobe is with us and um we kind
of have his spirit in those jerseys
adm i'm wondering what it felt like
after you hit that shot and then you
turn around and you're running back
towards your bench and you see
all your teammates running at you and um
you ran over taelynn and like was it all
just a blur
or did you what do you remember about
that moment and what it felt like
um i remember the play before
you know i got the floater they come
down we knew he was going to jokic
and you know i let him get to his
strength with his right hand
you know he got a hook score they go up
uh
one and i was kind of upset because i'm
a better defensive player than that
and uh granted he made a great play you
know he he made great plays
throughout the course of the game and
rondo told me he said
you know he's already he scored on you
you go you go
you know get it back so uh
came off made the shot um and then
the first person i saw was swish you
know just
just jumping around everywhere and uh i
just kind of ran
towards the bench and uh knocked tailing
over
and i don't know i mean it's a great
moment it's a great moment to be to be
with the team
and they're chairing for you celebrating
for you um
you know like i said it'd be especially
it was in staples you know with our fans
but
to have the guys that we have the
brotherhood that we have on this team
the support you know that i have you
know every player i have on this team
from
ownership to the coaching staff to you
know the
the training staff to the players and
everybody's
one big family and to to be here and you
know cheer for me and support me through
that shot and then you know after
celebrating especially moments like this
that you that you keep forever
hey anthony uh rajan called this the
biggest shot of your career so far
um you're obviously on this stage um you
know it's the lakers franchise
obviously you you you know it you get it
is this what you wanted
when you when you left new orleans and
when you were looking for a change and
is this the sort of kind of moment and
experience that that you were looking
for
uh it's for sure the biggest shot of my
career and
you know when i left um i just want to
be i just want to
be able to compete for a championship um
and i know that you know moments like
this comes with it
especially being in la the biggest
market in
basketball you know i know
the quote-unquote pressure is going
going beyond us going to be on me
especially the first year with
everything that happened last year
and then also playing alongside braun
i know he gets criticized more than you
know any basketball player ever so
uh just being a just being able to to
play alongside him and
he you know he kind of helped me with
you know all this quote unquote pressure
um going on and playing you guys seeing
that in game five of the rockets you
know where he
you know comes to me at the sports table
and talk to me you know when i was
struggling so
um just go out there just playing
basketball he makes it a lot easier for
me
but um just being able to want this
you know type of pressure to talk to
spotlight um
and go out and and play in big games and
make you know
big time plays a big-time shot for my
team so um
definitely what i wanted and you know
the job is definitely not over
until we able to you know
win a ring i mean that's that's when
it's over and that's when the test was
completed so i mean
you know it was a big shot like i said
we were celebrating for a couple hours
but
um you know the same fault you know they
could have easily won this game and we
got to be
ready for game three
no thanks um lebron brought up
the shot you had against brooklyn did
not go in
um you know how how much has that shot
sort of influenced in the months since
your
uh your ability to kind of get ready for
taking another shot and getting another
look just like that one
i mean i mean the first
like four days i was talking to him like
like damn i should have made that shot
for you like i got to make that shot for
you he's like man you're fine you're
fine
you know um but like i i put more
pressure on myself than anybody
i feel like every shot i take is
supposed to go in and you know i have
enough confidence in my shots
to make those type of plays um and then
i knew that i just
i was going to have an opportunity you
know tonight to make
you know almost the same exact shot from
the same exact spot
and this time i i think just missing
that shot in
and you know making making
a three earlier from that same exact
spot just gives you gives me a lot of
confidence having this
you know this team giving me a lot of
confidence and shooting the ball coach
want me to shoot more threes
you know i'm having accomplishment to
shoot those so
um you know situation like that you know
having this team
you know and this coaching staff who
believes in you to make plays like that
and to you know draw plays up for you or
um things like that to to make you take
those big shots
um puts a lot of confidence in in myself
and
accomplishing you know in my game where
i can go up and make those type of plays
all right just a couple more here
really about being at this level that
you didn't expect kendall walker said
the other day
that despite all his experience in the
league now that he's finally in the
conference finals just that
every possession mattering so much is
there anything that you've noticed
despite being on a league yeah i mean
he's right
every possession does matter um you know
24 turnovers tonight i mean we gave them
24 more possessions we turned the ball
over we got to get shots at the rim and
you know things like that matter details
matter
um you know because you know now
it seems to make you pay you know and we
can't afford to
you know teams are already good enough
you know to get this far
that they're going to make plays and
when we you know have mistakes
defensively breakdowns offensively um
not talking
not spreading back on defense or
whatever um and we get them
you know extra points then uh we put it
we make it a lot harder for us to win a
game so
um i say team teams are
are great at this level um who made it
this far players
are a lot better than you know teams you
might see in the first round so
uh you never want to give them extra
possessions and um
you know this guy to my left is a
constant reminder
you know of of how we should play and
and the details and
what what it takes to win championships
and he constantly preaches that in the
timeouts in the film room because he's
been there
um and we want we want to we want to be
there too
so uh details matter and
you know possession is definitely a
possession game when you get this you
know lay in the playoffs
all right last two have dan and one on
a plate like that zero of the details
get lost how good was the pass from
john was your specialized was moving
were you surprised how clean of a look
you ended up with
um i think doe wanted to come in and
make that pass
obviously he's kevin brown our best
passers on the team
um but i knew if i
had a look you know clean look to come
off he was he's going to put it on the
money
and i mean it's crazy because he had a
yoke he's like seven feet right he had a
footer on him and he uh i set it on a
chest pad that some people
make you know it probably got deflected
he threw a bounce pass you know where
he couldn't get to it and it landed
right in my hands and
i'm not sure what happened on the back
side with their defense but you know
when i came off
and i saw nobody in front of me um it
really just about taking your time and
knocking down the shot but
um he threw a great pass and i said it's
my job on this team
you know along with ross to make plays
like that for us
last question brad turner
congratulations lady
um the last 20.8 seconds after jokic
made the shot
take us through those times because
caruso misses a shot danny gets his shot
blocked you don't have
time left ronald comes in you
shot those last 20.8 seconds what was
that like what was going through the
whole team's
mind yeah i mean we knew we had no time
off ac had a great look at the top of
the key
danny got the rebound uh dribble dog try
to get a two-pointer
uh murray blocker went out of bounds had
2.8 left or
something like that and uh we're running
this play
you know for ron who hit multiple game
winners in his career to
to take us home and uh i just saw how
you know they were playing it um like
kind of off of me so i knew if i kind of
flew around
you know with them kind of locked in on
braun uh
i'm gonna probably have a clean look and
i kind of just looked at dope
and we made eye contact and um
you know he made a great pass you know
and you end up making a shot but
um it was like a crazy possession i mean
we had a couple good looks
you know you know most people will you
know give up on plays it was a huge
officer rebound for danny
to get us that possession so um
credit goes to him as well for for
battling inside
um you know we came out with victoria so
um you know everybody played you know
great tonight with the team effort and
like i said we gotta get ready for for
game three
thanks sadie thanks thanks everyone on
zoom ali thanks everyone
hey lebron um last time you're in the
playoffs
uh you know you made a couple game
winners
and it seemed to be something that is
become such a big part of your kind of
skill set and persona on the court these
days so
what's it like to see a teammate that
clearly you have great chemistry with
that
you wanted to have be in la with you
be the guy to make that shot and and win
this game for you guys
did you see my reaction that's all smile
nah did you see my reaction after you
made it i i
i didn't get to see everything i watched
on tv i was on tv
i tried to chase them down just like
every last one of the teammates and
staff that we had out there
a special moment for a special player
happy to be a part of it
what is it what does it take to
take on the pressure to make a to first
of all want a shot like that to take it
to make it
um and what do you think the fact that
he was able to
have that kind of moment will do for his
confidence going forward in situations
like this
well it's not about making a shot it's
about having a belief
of just taking it for one and living
with the result
you know um i i think right back you
know to
our game right before uh cover hit
we played brooklyn at home and he had a
similar shot right there on that left
wing right in front of their bench
for us to win the game and he missed it
and he was down on himself but at the
end of the day i told him i said listen
man
if you open and and i was able to drive
you know that particular game and find
him wide open and he just missed it but
it's just the
the confidence to take the shot you're
not going to make them all
but the belief that just take it in
and live with the results is what it's
all about and you know tonight was
you know his moment tonight was his
moment to just you know
find a space um you know hunt the ball
down
uh you know in our top 10 and it says
one of our top ten ministers leaders and
rondo was able to find him
and he knocked it down um big time big
time play
ali even before that
he and jokic were trading buckets um
i mean were you just getting the sense
that he was sort of rising to
that particular duel um even before that
game-winning shot
no it's not about an individual a
match-up it's about us trying to
execute in him just coming through for
us and um
you know that's what he did it wasn't
okay joker your turn my turn when i was
just about playing the game
and finding ways to try to make an
impact um
you know obviously those two big shots
he had at the end one was the floater to
take the lead
and joker was able to get the tip in and
then him he comes back with the three
um you know just uh you know just big
time plays like i said for a big time
player
okay rachel brown
had a skill set to do this for a long
time but that he is now with the team
that is at a championship level
competing for a championship competing
for conference finals
what do you think that's like for him
and finally get to be in the big moments
that match disability yeah
i don't know um it's definitely an 80
question but
just happy to have him i know what he
brought to the table i know what he's
about
i know his skill set and
you know that's why i wanted him here so
so badly
chris you guys
didn't have a timeout on that last play
like this how
were you able to talk about the scenario
in which
something like that could happen before
that's this floor right here that we're
on right now is all about
it's the practices it's the shooter
rounds and we
talk about every every single scenario
possible up three
down three up two down two do we have a
foul to give
do we not do we have a timeout do we not
are we going full court
half court bob which is a baseline out
of bounds sob sideline out of bounds
you know you talk about all those things
and for
you want to be a championship ball club
you have to be able to do that on the
fly
so knowing that we didn't have a timeout
we were able to get into a situation
into a set that we worked on in practice
and get right to it and the first option
was for me if doe saw me over the top
if not the a.d flashes in the rest is
history
lebron it's not making the shot it's
taking it
um caruso stepped into the shop
similarly
took it right away um he's been really
vocal
in huddles and stuff like that where
does he kind of fit
on your leadership hierarchy on this
team how valuable is that part of
his confidence to speak up and step in
and take a shot
when you're trying to play high level
basketball you got to have high level iq
players
and he's one of them and not only does
he have high level
iq he also plays with a high energy
and we know we're going to get out of
him every night it's not about him
making shots
but we know he's going to defend um and
he's going to play
um at a level that he's capable of
playing at and we all know that once he
checks into the game every single night
so
we know what to expect out of him and
you know to be honest when he makes
shots is
it's extra credit for us um but he puts
that work in
on his offensive skill set to get better
and better and uh
you know we love everything about
absolutely absolutely i will throw back
to tanisha
mike trudeau hey lebron mike tridel in
la uh if i could jump off the court for
a second
if i read the the uh sweatshirt
correctly he said change
isn't made from watching on the
sidelines you're more than a vote
sweatshirt that you were on the way in
i just wanted to ask you about that and
where your mindset is uh
as these as this run continues and where
your mind is
outside of the court i should say for
sure i mean i i know we're here you know
playing the game but i'm not losing the
the fact of you know what's important as
well and more than the vote is about
you know protecting black voters and and
voter suppression that goes on in our
communities
um you know and like you said it's not
changes are made
by sitting on the uh on the sidelines
and that's one that's one of our slogans
and we're very proud of that and
you know getting you know the people
that want to join us getting them gear
and wearing the t-shirts wearing the
hats and wearing the hoodies
because when they go in their community
it's something they can continue to
enlighten continue to educate continue
to you know make people
empower about this movement and um
you know because you know we always talk
about change you know in our communities
and now we have an opportunity we have
an opportunity to really create change
for the better and um and we look
forward to this opportunity
and if i could flip back uh to the court
going back to 2009
remember the bank shot of course you do
uh but the shot against orlando
uh like what was it like that night
going to sleep and i know this is a
question for ad2 but
what is that to hit a shot that you kind
of dream of growing up right isn't isn't
that kind of what that situation is
um i mean to be completely honest man um
it was
probably one of the greatest moments in
my career up until that point and you
know
just knowing the situation we were about
to go down o2
um you know and we had home court
advantage and uh we knew how
how powerful that orlando team was you
know playing against actually my
teammate right now in dwight so
you know for me to be able to hit that
shot it was a huge moment for me and i'm
still a young young kid at the time so
um big time
um the one thing i wish a.d had tonight
with the shot that he made i wish we
were playing at staples
i wish this i mean we miss our fans so
much and i can only imagine
um you know i probably blew the roof off
staples center a.d hitting that shot
tonight in staples with our crowd
um i would have loved for him to have
that moment because i know what i felt
like for me
when i was able to hit that shot as you
mentioned versus orlando and eastern
congress finals
game two at the buzzer last few
questions
hey lebron a.d has talked about just how
much he's leaned on you throughout the
playoffs
and obviously he's played outstanding in
the western conference finals i'm
curious what's the biggest thing
that you've tried to instill in him
during this time
um i think just staying even keel
that's what it's all about the playoffs
in the postseason and the more
the more you advance into the postseason
um the emotions and the adversity
and it's going to be a rollercoaster at
times um if you could just
you know no matter if you're up no
matter if you're down being able to keep
your composure and keep
your mindset on the main thing is um
it's very important um you know and
you know this is uh the furthest he's
got in his career up until this point
and i'm just happy to be here with him
to you know give any advice gives me
give any advice on him to lean on me or
you know i mean to be completely honest
[ __ ] in the second half
i leaned on him you know and he brought
us home you know so i just tried to set
the example
early on and uh and we leaned on him
especially in the fourth quarter and he
brought us home
lebron you um anthony came to
asking for this pressure and asking for
this kind of burden to be a great player
in the playoffs this is obviously a
process that you've gone through
what is the the challenge for an athlete
both to ask for that to seek that out
but then also to perform when that
moment comes
um i don't know i think for me
personally
um it's always been about the manning
arena
you know the quote from theodore
roosevelt um
you know it's about the guy that's in
the arena that's
you know that's gone through everything
the blood to sweat the tears
you know and in our situation the
competition but it's about
the work that you put in and belief in
yourself it's not about the
doubters or the naysayers or the people
who's gonna talk about you and try to
slander you and put you down and bring
you down every single day
it's not about them because they've
never been in an arena they don't
understand
so you know a.d he know how special he
is
and when he don't i'll be the first one
to tell him how special he is
and you know he wanted to be here
i'm happy he wanted to be here uh you
know because if he didn't we wouldn't
have a moment like tonight so
that's what it's all about but you know
you put that pressure on yourself when
you don't really care about what other
people think because what other people
think
it doesn't really matter because they
don't understand anybody can talk from
outside
um but if they got into the ring or they
got into the arena
probably ten times out of ten that [ __ ]
depends
thanks